[Music]
this is sky news today it's one o'clock
the headlines a third attempt is
underway to help civilians flee
ukraine's major cities by humanitarian
corridors
russia's slow progress towards kiev
continues with tanks again on the move
while areas around the capital have
already been completely flattened
eight houses here that have been
flattened utterly flattened there were
about six people from one family who
died here three of them were children
also coming up ukraine claims to have
shot down a russian plane over the
southern city
we never wanted this war
but
this war was brought to us
we never wanted to kill anyone
but we have to fight back
meanwhile thousands continue to stream
across ukraine's western borders but the
uk government's criticized for its
stance towards refugees
we're processing thousands uh right now
we will continue
to make sure that we have a very very
generous approach
and in her first post-covert meeting the
queen welcomes a canadian prime minister
who's in the uk to discuss ukraine
[Music]
hello good afternoon russia says there's
now a temporary cease-fire in some parts
of the country to allow civilians to
leave
it's the third attempt at setting up
humanitarian corridors after ukraine
accused russian forces of continuing to
fire during previous attempts
well ukrainian presidential advisor has
said that more than 900 communities in
the country are currently without light
water and heating
let's take you through the latest
developments now russia's defense
ministry says humanitarian corridors
opened at seven o'clock this morning uk
time to allow civilians to escape from
kiev mario paul kharkiv and sumi after
two failed attempts to allow civilians
to leave mario paul
a third round of talks between russian
and ukrainian nicosia negotiators in
belarus is scheduled to start at two
o'clock this afternoon that's according
to an adviser to ukraine's president
meanwhile it's being reported that the
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov
will meet his ukrainian counterpart on
thursday
only around 50 visas in the uk have been
granted to ukrainian refugees so far and
that's despite more than 10 000 people
applying for the family visa scheme in
the last hour the prime minister said
that the uk could not abandon all checks
and controls in the process
and the cost of brent crude oil has
reached its highest level since 2008
passing 139
a barrel earlier this morning
let's take a look now at what's
happening on the ground the uk defenses
ministry ministry of defense said
russian forces made minimal advances on
the ground over the weekend and there's
evidence of ukraine fighting back in
some locations
russia has continued massive air and
artillery strikes on military and
civilian sites in cities across the
country
the assault has been particularly heavy
in the southern city of mario paul and
russian artillery is now pounding
nikolayev the next stop on the route to
the black sea hub of odessa
but the local governor says ukrainian
forces have retaken control of
nikolayev's airport
residential areas were targeted in
kharkiv overnight by russia
while a ukrainian official said the
nearby town of chernohith has been
retaken by ukraine
and fighting has been particularly heavy
on the outskirts of the capital kiev
in urban sky news witness civilians
being targeted while trying to escape
skies tom clark has the latest
i'll give two missiles streak into the
night sky an instant later a fireball
lights up the city
ukrainian armed forces claim this is the
moment they shot down a russian aircraft
during a bombardment but sky news has
been unable to verify their claim
the bombardment was really enough this
residential block in kharkiv struck by a
missile before fading back to blackout
on another front in this war mikolav in
southern ukraine another residential
block destroyed but the horror is just
the same
let's show everyone
all the windows are blown off and the
doors as well
their situation becoming ever more
desperate ukraine's president zielenski
renewed his calls for tougher sanctions
against russia
if the invasion continues and russia
doesn't give up its plans in regards to
ukraine then a new set of sanctions
needs to be introduced
if somebody loses their mind we have to
lose fear and forget about commerce we
need to defend ourselves both countries
and companies must take a moral stand
and fight against an inhumane force
which wants to destroy humanity itself
there's talk of a ban on russian oil
imports as the us secretary of state met
with nato ally lithuania
they are having a dramatic impact
already
we see
the ruble going through the floor we see
russia's credit rating coming basically
to zero to junk status as we would call
it we see its stock market shut down we
see an exodus of virtually every leading
company
from russia all of those things are
happening they're happening in real time
russian defense ministry footage that we
cannot verify purports to show their
jets in the skies above ukraine and
tanks advancing
ukrainian officials dismissed russia's
six proposed evacuation corridors which
led either to russia belarus or other
parts of ukraine
don't trust putin putin never keep their
promises about humanitarian corridor
during the eight years of war would he
never keep promises for the releasing
the hostages during eight years of war
and i'm not very much optimistic frankly
speaking and the refugee crisis only
deepens 1.7 million people are now
estimated to have fled ukraine as
pressure is mounting on the uk after it
was reported only 50 visas had been
issued to ukrainian refugees i'm not
sure those numbers are right but we're
processing thousands as i uh as i speak
to you and clearly this
this crisis is evolving the whole time
and i've i've said before that the uk
will be
as generous as we can possibly be that
generosity will be tested this conflict
is only expected to worsen and with it
the desperation of millions more to get
out of harm's way tom clark sky news
just have some breaking news coming in
to bring you now and this is that um the
eu's charles michelle says that they
will be discussing ukraine's membership
for applying to the eu and that is the
latest that's just coming in now of
course if you remember ukraine has
applied to be a member of the eu the
process takes a very long time as you
can imagine but ukraine is calling for
all of those steps of course to be
bypassed to speed up the process the
other breaking news to bring you also
comes from america which is that the u.s
president joe biden is here to hold a
call with um france's macron emmanuel
macron this will be at around 2 30 so
not long to go at all just over an
hour's time this will be of course um
the latest coming in from the white
house if you recall emmanuel macron is
the person who has been speaking to um
vladimir putin in the last
few hours actually spoke to him just
yesterday paving the way for that latest
humanitarian corridor this is a third
try the past two failed over the weekend
so it's a process of watching to see if
this latest one does of course hold so
the latest coming in now is that the eu
will be meeting to discuss ukraine's
membership and um president joe biden is
due to hold um some talks with um
francis emmanuel macron that will be
taking place at 2 30 gmt
russia's ministry of defense insisted
today that the humanitarian corridors
were now open but ukraine's deputy prime
minister said that the fact that they
headed towards russia made them
unacceptable
today since 10 am moscow time russia
declared a silence regime and opened six
humanitarian corridors
the first one from kiev to hommel the
other two from mario paul to zapariccia
and roston
one from kharkiv to belgarrod and two
from suny to belgrade and portala
detailed information about the
humanitarian corridors was given to the
ukrainian side in advance as well as
dedicated entities of the un osce and
international committees of the red
cross for the period of humanitarian
corridors opening russian armed forces
of the russian federation will be
continually and objectively monitoring
the evacuation process by using unmanned
aerial
vehicles let's show you then what this
means a defense ministry spokesman said
that six corridors were open as of 7 am
gmt
to allow civilians to safely leave the
cities of kiev kharkiv sumi and mario
paul
but four of the six fruits that he
talked about leading to belarus or
russia something that ukraine's deputy
prime minister says is unacceptable
and she demanded that the russians
accept alternative routes to elsewhere
in ukraine
this is an unacceptable option of
creating humanitarian corridors our
people from ivankov daimar fishgarad and
kiev won't go to belarus to fly later to
russia
well let's bring in our security and
defense editor deborah haynes who's in
la viv and deborah the latest of course
that we're hearing from if you take a
look at the area of mikolai for example
the governor of nikolayev stating that
ukrainian forces have retaken the
regional airport there so certainly
putin underestimating the resilience of
the people of ukraine and it also
appears that cracks are developing in
the latest move for humanitarian
corridors
yes i mean this it's a it's a fluid
battle isn't it there's um absolutely no
sense that russian forces have come into
this country and manage to push to all
the objectives they wanted to go to um
far from it they've met very stiff
resistance even in city well kerson is
the only city big city that um has uh
has fallen as it were to uh russian
forces civilians are still out in the
streets as images of them protesting
against the the russian presence and um
shouting pro-ukrainian um chants so it's
there's no sense that this is uh any
kind of easy push um on the russian side
and yes like you're talking about
nikolayev that's in the the southern um
along the southern coast of ukraine
which has seen heavy bombardments mario
pole another of those cities there which
has had people effectively besieged
under fire in their basements unable to
get food water
communications there is very difficult
to try to even speak to families there
to find out how they are um is very very
difficult and medical supplies also
running out which is why the need for
this for these humanitarian corridors is
so great and yet as you are describing
they too have have become um politicized
it's not just a neutral uh humanitarian
corridor some of these are humanitarian
corridors uh in the direction of the
country that's behind the bombardments
of the cities and as you've heard from
the ukrainian side they're seeing that
as unacceptable it's also worth noting
that the same kind of tactic was used by
russia when it intervened in syria
on behalf or in support of the assad
regime
and bombarded cities like aleppo then
opened up humanitarian corridors to
allow people to go to areas held by the
regime a regime that they opposed and
it's kind of a similar scenario is
what's being painted here and all the
while it's the people that are suffering
many of them you've heard like it's what
more than one and a half million
refugees now the fastest growing flood
of refugees since the second world war
according to the united nations and many
of them coming here to the west which is
still relatively peaceful and safe and
then crossing over the border into eu
countries like poland and like you like
romania where they're seeking refuge
there and as you can see from the
weather behind me it's cold here too so
not only are they leaving homes they're
leaving homes with scant belongings and
they don't know when they're going to
come back or where they're going to end
up
deborah in la vie thank you
well underground in ukraine some areas
around the capital have been destroyed
our special correspondents alex crawford
has the latest now from near kiev
there's about eight houses here that
have been flattened utterly flattened
there were about six people from one
family who died here three of them were
children one of about 12 years old the
other one i think was also an older
teenager
unbelievably a couple of civilians
survived the people that we've been
talking to who are picking through the
rubble and you've got to remember this
is an entirely residential area it's
filled with farm houses
and homes
they say that they're now
reduced to trying to find just any
documents or any
bits of possessions for the one of the
men who managed to survive one of the
men of the family who managed to survive
there were two two of the grandchildren
were staying in that partially um
standing building there who also managed
to survive
but look at what these bombs have done
and they they the people who were around
the village spoke of hearing three
really loud explosions as as bombs were
dropped and the they they're obviously
now utterly terrified they this happened
a couple of days ago on friday
um they're still reeling from the shock
of it all and i think it follows a
pattern of an increasing number of
civilians and civilian targets or
civilian locations
which appear to be um targeted or
certainly not
um off the agenda of the the the russian
war machine
here they i told you they're trying to
pick through the remnants of whatever's
left here just to find official
documents and um anything that um
that the family that the family members
who survived can grasp onto and a number
of these are
um i think this this gentleman is a is a
relative and we spoke to them earlier
they they only speak uh ukrainian but
they were saying about how they've spent
the past couple of days just sifting
through
all of this
um and trying to make sense of what
happened they're
they're pretty much in shock to be
honest and very concerned about the in
the increasing
what they see and perceive as increasing
attacks
the woman that you see there who's been
going through
all the rubble um had some pretty choice
words for the um the russian president
um when when i asked her about what what
she she thought about was happening in
this area and we know that yesterday
we're in a completely different area
where um civilians who were trying to
flee an active combat zone were being
fired on as they were trying to flee
so
there is no civilian at the moment in in
ukraine who feels particularly safe at
the moment there are no international
laws it seems which are being observed
and a lot of
anger and hesitation earlier we were
talking to the former ukrainian
president petra polish poroshenko who
was
on the one hand saying how grateful he
was uh to britain america a number of
other countries um in the west who've
rallied to ukraine's support but also
demanding so much more
urging so much more action saying that
he he was incredibly bullish about the
prospects of ukraine
actually succeeding in this um david and
goliath battle you know because the
ukrainian military is pretty much
dwarfed by the russian one and uh the
numbers of of russian soldiers but he
feels that they have the courage the
determination the defiance however
he says they need
so much more they need
aircraft they need the fly the skies to
be closed he's demanding he they want
more weapons they want much more unified
response basically from the
international community and he had some
fairly cautionary and chilling
words about how this you know this isn't
just ukraine's fight this is the whole
world fight he believes it's a real
um defense
of democracy and freedom and he felt
like
the reticence of the rest of the world
not to get involved he felt was almost
foolhardy because sooner or later he
said they are going to get involved
the rest of the world is going to get
involved unless
the russian leader is stopped but this
this is a
scene of utter utter and complete
devastation and
nowhere have we seen anything that even
comes close to a military target
that's our special correspondent alex
crawford they're bringing us the latest
from near levitt um from near kiev there
now the prime minister has defended
britain's visa scheme for ukrainians
saying that thousands of applications
are being processed and this comes after
the home office said that at the weekend
that only around 50 visas had been
granted by yesterday morning well let's
go live now to our political
correspondent kate mccann and kate boris
johnson speaking earlier on saying that
the uk is generous to people fleeing war
zones but looking at that figure 50 that
doesn't appear to be very generous does
it and also there has been some
confusion about a third visa route what
more can you tell us well boris johnson
actually disputed that number of 50
applications which have been processed
so far he said that there would be
further numbers later on today and
indicated that he said over 10 000
applications had been received by the
home office my understanding is that
number is 13
500 so far but you're right that there
have been some questions about what the
uk government is doing because you can
see from alex's reporting there the
scenes of utter devastation in ordinary
residential neighborhoods which mean
that people are fleeing ukraine at a
desperate rate you know over a million
people now leaving heading over the
border to poland to other areas close to
ukraine and then from there some of them
looking to come to the uk because they
may well have family members here now
that route the family route was set out
last week and the prime minister said
around 200 000 maybe more people could
come to the uk using that particular
scheme there's been some criticism about
it being quite slow about people having
to go to biometric appointments to get
their details checked the government is
not going to get rid of those checks
they are worried about security they're
going to keep them in place but there's
a second route too a humanitarian route
which involves sponsorship and that's
the one that there's been some questions
over because last week we understood it
was being set up but overnight pretty
would tell speaking to the sun newspaper
appeared to indicate that that could be
widened even more to make it something a
little bit more like the european union
scheme which is that any ukrainian
fleeing can have a sanctuary if you like
in a european union country so still
some questions i think about how far the
uk is willing to go but the prime
minister himself indicated the uk would
be generous but would not have an open
border system there would be still
checks and controls partly because
there's been some concern in the past
over immigration now serkia strama the
labour leader has been pretty with the
prime minister all the way through this
so far but he's indicated today that he
has some concerns about the way the home
office is operating
i think some sort of emergency
protection visa would work well but it's
got to be absolutely straightforward and
we've got to play our part coordinated
across
our allies of course but we have to play
our part and the home office is in a
complete mess about this they just need
to sort it out and the sooner the better
and the other item on the agenda today
for boris johnson is sanctions you saw
some pictures there just before of the
prime minister meeting with president
trudeau the canadian uh president prime
minister rather he will also be meeting
with his dutch counterpart this
afternoon and speaking to president
biden on the phone about what more can
be done with sanctions now both the
dutch and the canadians are very keen to
go further to do more on economic
sanctions just like the uk government
has been suggesting it wants to do too
and the prime minister indicated that
maybe swift could be pushed further some
more difficult economic curbs on russia
to try and stop president putin in his
tracks but of course there's been that
criticism about individuals and whether
here in the uk enough has been done to
stop russian oligarchs from hoarding
their wealth and assets there will be a
bill going through the house of commons
this afternoon which is the economic
crime bill which will aim to toughen up
some of those measures although labour
say it still doesn't go far enough
kate thank you
let's just bring you some breaking news
that's just coming into us now which is
that the human rights office saying that
it has recorded
406 civilian deaths in ukraine
801 injuries since the start of the war
so that's the latest that's just coming
into us now from the u.n which says that
it has recorded
406 civilian deaths in ukraine and 801
injuries of course then um the real
number could be much higher and that
those figures are obviously trickling
through to us now the refugee
situation of course also increasing so
far we have about 1.7 million people who
have fled um ukraine so far
well as i was just saying there so far
more than 1.7 million people haven't
fled ukraine so far with poland alone
accepting more than a million refugees
almost 80 000 people have also crossed
into romania
our correspondent alistair bunkel has
this update from the town of cirit on
the romanian side of the ukrainian
border
it's the same hour after hour day after
day
we've witnessed just a steady stream a
constant stream
of families coming over the border the
ukrainian border is two or three hundred
yards that way then you've got no man's
land and then you've got the romanian
checks the queues on the other side of
the border are long they're making sure
that no fighting age men
are leaving they've got to stay once
they get this side it is much
slicker they've got very little on them
one suitcase two suitcases maybe all
they can carry really so what they leave
home with that is all they come with
they are met by the fire brigade here
who look after them
but almost all of them are on foot they
can't bring their cars
partly because
in many cases their husbands or fathers
have to keep the cars uh to operate
still in ukraine but most of them are
coming actually by coach across the
country from cities like kharkiv from
dimi pro from kiev
and that is why they're on foot and then
they get brought into the system here
and they get taken to wherever they want
to go some have a plan
and so they get taken off the railway
station they get taken to the airport
many do not have a plan
which means they get looked after by
local charities local organizations they
get taken into uh people's houses let's
move out the way to let these guys pass
you can see here the fire brigade come
up and they help them with help them
carrying the luggages
some of them pick up small children as
well and help them that way
but they will go now to people's houses
around the region uh they'll go to
hotels that have some makeshift
temporary centers
whilst if they need papers to be
processed those are processed and whilst
they basically work out what it is they
want to do and where they want to go to
and the romanians here will help them do
that
but you know we have not seen a slowdown
if anything the tempo has
increased in recent days we haven't seen
a slowdown on people coming through here
uh it is just as i said at the beginning
a constant stream
alistair bunker with that latest and i
have some more breaking news coming in
for you and that is that ukraine's
delegation have arrived in belarus for
talks with russia and this is according
to the belarusian news agency belter so
the talk is due to be held at two
o'clock so not very long to go at all
just over half an hour there so
negotiations between russian and um
ukrainians due to be held at two o'clock
in belarus and the confirmation is that
the ukrainian delegation have now
arrived in belarus for talks we'll be
staying across that for you please stay
with us here on sky news coming up
we'll take a closer look at russia's
movements on the ground in ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they fear they'll be
killed
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day can't access those and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber bullets
see fire's all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches
siobhan robbins sky news bangkok
welcome back let's take a closer look
now at the strategic situation on the
ground in ukraine sky's anna jones is
here to tell us more
vanessa thanks very much indeed well
here with me is michael clark our
defense and security analyst and michael
let's start off talking about
humanitarian corridors because the
russians have proposed some routes for
some but the ukrainians have rejected
them so while i mark them on the map
give us an idea of why they would turn
them down
yes i mean the ukrainians are turning
these these roots down for a number of
reasons i mean one is that these roots
mainly go into russian-held areas which
ukrainian is not that keen to do
um two is that these routes would have
to be open for quite a long time if
they're to get out people in significant
numbers from really some pretty big
cities i mean 200 000 people alone from
mario paul and i mean if these routes do
work it'd have to stay open for many
days when they this arrangement comes to
an end the russians would then be able
to say right everyone who wanted to
leave us left so now we will assume that
everyone still in the city is a
combatant they've obviously decided to
stay and fight us
okay so let's take a look at the south
of the country shall we because the
attacks on the main cities of course are
continuing and let's take a look at
odessa first of all shall we tell us why
odessa is so important
to the russians and what's the situation
there at the moment yes odessa's the key
port on the black sea along with cherno
morse for a bit bit further south it
controls the economy of ukraine it's
their ability to to trade by sea to get
all the grain and the bulk goods out and
get imports in they can bring stuff
through poland on by road but you can't
get the tonnages by road that you can by
sea so it's pretty important and we have
had
some kind of attack going on today
haven't we yes the russians are at uh
fighting at mikolayev just uh to the uh
east of odessa mklev is the gateway to
odessa the ukrainians seem to have
repelled the first big attack they are
now fighting there at some point the
russians will hope to get around mklev
and move towards odessa when they do as
you've indicated there there is a task
force at sea there's a series of assault
ships are waiting offshore they've been
waiting a bit of a while now but as and
when a land attack develops almost
certainly a seaborne attack will go in
with it and what about of casson this is
the major city that russia has managed
to take but how much control have they
got there well they're in control of
kershaw and in the sense that they're
there but reports are that all the
russian troops are in barracks the city
is going about its business reasonably
normally it's hard to see how the
russians can benefit much from kershawn
except using it as a base to reinforce
but i'm not sure where they're going to
get the reinforcements from to be honest
and what about mario paul because we've
heard a lot about the bombardment that
mario pole is undergoing and troops
surrounding the city there is that kind
of what they're aiming to do across the
country that kind of strategy we we have
feared that the agony of mario paul is
the model for the rest of the country
it's been surrounded for several days it
should have fallen in the first hours of
the attack on day 12 it still is still
there but the water is cut off uh
electricity is cut off food is running
short it's it's a medieval siege
and that may now turn out to be the
model for other cities in the country
and civilian areas clearly are being
targeted there's no ambiguity about it
now there was a couple of days ago the
russians might have made an argument
that they were going for strategic
targets now clearly these are civilian
uh bombing bombing of civilian areas
very deliberately can we assume then
that that is what is being planned for
kiev as well if we take a look at a map
of the north of the country as well and
take a look at
kiev this is still in ukrainian hands of
course
but
what's happening to the convoy that's
outside the city are they making
progress or not the convoy is still
stationary after six days but aries and
some of the battalion tactical groups
are moving westwards they're breaking
west out of the area of the convoy and
they're moving around to the south of
kiev other forces are moving in from the
northeast so kiev will be surrounded we
guess in the next few days and then
there's a psychology of it when the
russians have surrounded kiev the
message to the government will be do you
want us to do to you what we did to
mario paul and what we've done to kirky
or do you want to give up now um and
that's the dilemma which the russians
will find themselves in but it's a
dreadful choice for the government of
kiev to have to make as well and and
just briefly how much do we know about
what's happening within the convoy and
the sense of morale as well
morale seems to be quite low the latest
information the convoy is trying to
decongest itself from the back they're
trying to back up but they are
completely stuck the uh ukrainians are
attacking the convoy and the convoy's
own supplies are running low they looked
as if they've used up all their
ammunition the first three days because
the ukrainians fought so hard and they
can't go forward with no ammunition but
the ammunition can't get there because
the roads are all blocked and there's
too much mud either side so they've got
themselves into a real problem one
russian blogger military blogger
described the convoy as a self-propelled
prisoner of war camp
michael thank you
thank you
you're watching sky news coming up the
latest on a new round of intensive
diplomatic efforts getting underway
today
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the prime minister is
making a big diplomatic push this week
for the west to take a tougher stance
against russia he's been hosting the
dutch and canadian prime ministers this
morning and will have a phone call with
the leaders of the u.s germany and ger
and france later this afternoon well
joining me now is constance diane
galicia who's a former ukrainian
ambassador to the eu grateful for your
time in sky news this afternoon now in
the last few minutes ukrainian
delegation have arrived in belarus for
talks which are due to begin at 2 00 pm
so just about 20 minutes time with
russia that's according to belarusian
news agency belter now realistically
what do you think can achieve from the
talks this time around
um
mr yelissaev can you hear me
apologies we appear to be having some
problems with the audio though we will
try and get that back up for you
elsewhere the queen has carried out her
first in-person meeting since recovering
from covert she met the canadian prime
minister justin trudeau at windsor
castle this morning he's here to discuss
the war in ukraine with boris johnson
and skies and brady joins us now so
ender what more can you tell us about um
this meeting this morning so this is
significant as you say it is the queen's
first in-person meeting with a leader
since she tested positive for the virus
that was on february the 20th uh taking
place at windsor castle inside the oak
room and there you can see her majesty
chatting away
with the canadian prime minister justin
trudeau now she's met him several times
before when he was a child believe it or
not in the 1970s
his father pierre trudeau was one of the
longest serving prime ministers in
canadian political history so there is a
long-running link there and he has
certainly met the queen many many
decades ago when he was a little boy in
canada she's of course the queen of
canada and she has been there out of all
the commonwealth nations it is the
country who she has visited the most so
she is extremely fond of canada more
than 20 separate visits her majesty has
made over the years to canada and
crucially the picture a lot of royal
watchers will be looking at that picture
no sign of the walking stick that her
majesty has been using um for some time
now so that's not in the picture at all
and she looks very much back on her feet
after that bout of culvert and the
canadian prime minister heading off to
meet boris johnson and also the dutch
prime minister mark rutter to talk about
the unfolding situation in ukraine
and uh thank you
well sky news has spoken to a ukrainian
nanny who was working in the uk but is
now stranded in france unable to get
back to britain
and this of course is after heading to
poland to collect her mother and
daughter who had fled ukraine skies
aisha hurry and i spoke to her in paris
the number of ukrainian people who are
fleeing their nation to try and find
sanctuary in the uk is growing hour by
hour the problem is that once they get
here to france they're finding it
increasingly troublesome to get across
to the border either by ferry or by car
or even by train they find that being
turned away by border force officials
because they don't have the right
paperwork now these people that we've
spoken to either have links to the uk or
they know someone there already in some
form grandparents mothers fathers etc
but one person we spoke to is having
that exact issue her name is mariana
she's been working as a nanny for a
british couple based in london she
heard from her daughter her
eight-year-old daughter who was living
with her grandmother in western ukraine
just outside of la viv she heard from
her daughter
the bombs that were going off on her
doorstep she heard the explosion she
heard how frightened her daughter was
mariana took that decision to travel
to go and rescue her daughter from the
ukrainian poland border she arrived
there managed to scoop her up and
decided to bring her back to the uk but
this is as far as they can go she
explained to us today how difficult that
journey has been in trying desperately
to get her eight-year-old daughter back
to the uk because i have so many like
proof i live in uk you know and i think
when i come to airport and also with
this situation in ukraine maybe they
support you know they tell okay and
after this is your problem when you come
in uk we just
get you in
but they not give less like in they tell
call for ryanair just ask some paper
and i just drove them like everything
what i have so many proof like from home
office like
i have like hotel work they support me
they they pay me every week money i get
you know
and after this they say no
so
we going for hotel we come when we come
to hotel they say no nothing no room
free and i tell them where we can go
sleep outside
both
and she said where are you from when
she's just listening from ukraine and
she tell okay i will give you one room
and she give for us one room this lady
in poland
see you
well let's go back now to costianton
yelisev he's a former ukrainian
ambassador to the eu thank you for your
patience um with us there now in the
last few minutes as i was saying the
ukrainian delegation have arrived in
belarus and this is of course for talks
as a due to begin in just a few minutes
time at two o'clock so around about 15
minutes time that news we're getting
from the belarusian news agency so
realistically what do you think can be
achieved from these next round of
negotiations between the russian side
and the ukrainian side
yes so let's be realistic uh not too
much expectation from the upcoming round
of negotiations
maximum what we would prefer to achieve
this is of course to
create a so-called humanitarian corridor
in order to evacuate
ukrainian
citizens salary people women and
children from the
you know
cities
which are currently bombed by the
russian aircrafts by the way they're
using internationally prohibited bombs
like cluster bombs they're using also
soviet style bombs
weight of 500 kilograms so what putin is
doing here on the territory of ukraine
he behaves as a bloody butcher who broke
into a peaceful country and
kills elderly people women children and
so on
but of course in my view
now you the international leaders should
really demonstrate the real leadership
and to call on putin to sit down around
the table of negotiations and to try to
firstly to
stop this war because this war is
conducted by russia not only
against ukraine this is a war against
the collective west so that is why again
we call on
our eu countries we call on germany
france and of course the united states
and uk
to push on putin to sit down and to
negotiate the peace because all wars
must be ended by peace this is the very
important thing
but do you think that that realistically
again um will happen because in the
lead-up to these um last um
few days we've seen
many people
turning up to moscow to speak to
putin himself we've had world leaders
from across the globe showing up to
speak to him johnson from the uk went um
emmanuel macron
but we still are at this stage so
what what what's what's needed in order
to really pose a stop to this because
there's only so much talking isn't there
that we can keep um seeing and we just
need to see some some firm um action and
a stop to this war
look what we can understand this is the
language of strength and all leaders
should speak from this point of view and
also there should be a complex of
steps taken by the by the western
leaders uh number one to uh continue
with the devastating sanctions against
russia number two to continue to provide
more lethal defensive weapons to ukraine
including the uh
uh missile defen to help us to establish
missile
defense system and uh number three to
provide ukraine with economic
humanitarian and financial assistance
and uh the putin understands only when
uh
we
will speak in one voice i mean uh
ukrainian leadership eu leadership and
the u.s leadership and we
must understand that uh sanctions should
be really devastating sanctions from the
hell we must not stop now we need to act
on the based on the principle no single
days without sanctions but uh from our
experience back in 2014 and 2015 when
you know putin invaded in ukraine for
the first time uh we need also to uh
we would like to call on uh eu leaders
uh to influence on putin
to start uh
negotiations uh to stop this world it
was the case by the way back in uh 2014
uh now in my view what we are lacking
here in europe this is lack of real
leadership real european leadership in
order to uh press on putin
at that time back in 2014 there was a
leadership conducted by chancellor
america now we call on current
chancellor chancellor
and the president macron also too sure
to to show a real genuine european
leadership and to press on putin to stop
this war
so what you're saying is that you don't
feel that olaf schultz the current um
german chancellor is showing enough
leadership
yes uh uh
we from our ukrainian perspective we do
believe that all eu leaders
are not showing the
100 percent genuine leadership and by
the way the today's opinion porn in paul
in germany clearly showed that uh
uh even
ordinary german citizens do believe that
eu and the west is not doing enough in
order to stop the war he's not doing
enough to introduce a real devastating
sanctions again we you should understand
that we are fighting uh uh not only for
ukraine for ukrainian independence and
territorial integrity we're fighting for
the collective west we're fighting for
freedom we're fighting for democracy
ukraine currently is used by by putin as
a battlefield and we and the avant-garde
of this battlefield and you should
understand if ukraine failed everybody
would fail and the
the latest example the the attack of uh
russian uh
fighters on the ukrainian nuclear power
plants it showed that a nuclear
radiation
and the pollution does not have any any
borders
it's not covered by the nato article 5.
so that's why it's it's time for the
western leaders to wake up not to limit
by only limited sanctions
you should understand that the next will
be the turn of the uh baltic states paul
and sorry to mention about that finally
how many
people should be killed in ukraine how
many children
you know that you understand
sorry to be very emotional but currently
now in kiki with bomb
haki was born
putin who is erasing the ukrainian
cities from the
you know from the from the from the uh
ground
so that's why
our appeal to eu leader finally
to stop talking to stop express their
concern and to stop expressing their you
know uh dissatisfaction in their
numerous statements
but to start to act
this is what putin is afraid about
please do not afraid putin please help
ukraine this is our voice this is my
voice as an ordinary ukrainian citizen
to all collect u.s
so less talk from them and more action
as you are saying there thank you so
much indeed for your time there
constantine yelissaev grateful for your
time on sky news this afternoon thank
thank
you
well let's bring you some more breaking
news now the mayor of ukrainian town of
urban which is near kiev says that
evacuation of civilians is proceeding on
monday without any shelling of course
that is today so all eyes had been on
that um humanitarian corridor to see
whether that would be successful so the
latest coming in there is that that
appears to be going smoothly without any
shelling at all so we'll be keeping an
eye on that and bringing you the latest
as and when it develops here on sky news
now the war in ukraine has led to the
biggest movement of people since the
second world war
the u.n refugee agency says more than
1.7 million people have now fled ukraine
of those more than a million of them
have crossed into poland
180 000 have gone to hungary which has
changed his earlier hardline policy on
accepting refugees
nearly 130 000 have crossed into
slovakia more than 80 000 ukrainian
residents are now in moldova
while a similar number are in romania
it's important to note that huge numbers
have already passed through after
arriving in these countries an estimated
183 000 are now in other european
countries well we're now joined by
alison griffin who's the head of
conflict and humanitarian campaign at
save the children thanks for your time
here on sky news
this afternoon and just looking at those
numbers
is a staggering number of people
absolutely right it's unprecedented in
anything we've seen um since the second
world war i heard from the save the
children teams on the ground at the
border with romania this morning that
they're seeing children coming across
freezing cold it's been snowing for days
there they're absolutely exhausted
they've been queuing 60 odd hours to get
out of the country um some are going by
car some are going by train
children that we're seeing are unable to
even speak because they're so tired and
of course they're so shocked by what
they've seen in just the last week i
mean just
we all are standing with them imagining
what it would be like for us to have to
go through that with our children it's
absolutely unprecedented and of course
the international community needs to
respond in an appropriate way and the uk
as well as all other countries in europe
need to play their part to ensure that
these children aren't stuck in limbo and
that they reach safety and that they
have the well-being support they need as
quickly as possible
um you were just saying that the
international community needs to respond
in an appropriate way what to you do you
think is an appropriate way
well uh i see the news today that
britain has given out 50 visas um and
out of the 1.2 million refugees that
we've seen come out of ukraine so far in
just over a week that's clearly not its
fair share um i was hearing reports that
a single gym hall in a small mold over
town is now housing more ukrainian
refugees and the uk government has
allowed to enter in the whole of britain
um so
it's impossible to put a figure on this
at this stage because the escalat the
situation's evolving so quickly
but there has to be a safe route to
resettlement for ukrainian families
regardless of whether or not they have
family here so only allowing people with
family members to come even though
they've extended the definition of what
it means to be a family member is not a
big enough response from the uk
government to the breadth of this crisis
and alison how much aid have you been
able to get out
into the ground in ukraine
well right now on the borders is where
we're standing up teams
we're distributing warm clothes blankets
food kits water and hygiene kits things
like toothbrushes for people who've
crossed the border obviously imagine
what it's like to pick up a bag and flee
with all that you can carry and
so and also importantly because we're a
children's charity we're um supporting
children with things like soft toys and
helping them reach a place of safety but
the long-term impact has to be that
these families need safe routes out of
the country and safe places to be able
to resettle without the weighty
bureaucratic processes of going through
long and complex asylum claims
um we're also concerned about reports
that we've seen that there are um large
numbers of ukrainian children who've
been separated from their families and
they're alone at the border and
obviously these are one of the most
vulnerable groups of people
and
the uk government and european
government should of course prioritize
those children ensuring that they can
reach safety as quickly as possible
alison and just very quickly um because
of time but just very quickly how can
people here who are watching get
involved to help well the british people
have been amazingly amazingly generous
the dec has raised the equivalent of one
million pounds per hour since it
launched a few days ago which is
unprecedented for humanitarian crisis so
we need the uk government to step up and
put that powerful level of solidarity
that we're seeing from the public into
action so whatever you can do sign the
petitions that are out there write to
your mp create some momentum to show
that this solidarity that we have in the
country needs to be put into action
thank you alison griffin grateful for
your time thank you
you're watching sky news do stay with us
we'll bring you all the latest in
ukraine after this break
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you